amy's with us in albany new york hi amy
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi how are you great how can we help
well my husband and i have been together
for about 13 years
married for about 10. i
am the
responsible financial part of our
marriage
and i lost my job due to covid
uh so i've been kind of feeling
you know talking referencing anxiety
i've been feeling super
anxious you know regarding kind of
losing my job
and our finances he is like i said the
polar opposite of me
and i'm this has been a elephant in the
room
so to speak for our whole marriage and
i'm just trying to figure out how to get
him on the same page
as me what's he do for a living
um he works for a municipality doing
what
um he's like a commercial
building inspector oh okay all right
cool does he share that you are also the
responsible one
or does he think he is a responsible one
and he just lets you have some
at least a runner no he he shares that
i'm the responsible one
and i think kind of sometimes takes
advantage of that
okay all right well there's a whole
bunch of things going on here
uh that that uh
the reason i ask where i did for a
living is i'm trying to figure out how
to connect to him
and uh speak to him in a way that allows
him to hear it okay
when he's a building inspector and he
goes in and inspects a building if they
haven't followed the formula
to properly build the building the
stupid thing will fall in and it's his
job to throw a red flag right
um you guys are following a formula that
has a very
very very low statistical probability of
winning
with wealth building and of having a
high quality marriage
correct so the the millionaire study
that we did for chris hogan's book
almost all the 10 000 millionaires that
were married the vast majority of them
had a spouse that worked as their
partner and they worked together towards
common goals
and so they had shared finances they
were not roommates
okay so statistically if you want to be
a millionaire
you're doing it wrong okay that's kind
of what we're saying right if you just
want to say look at the
the data what's the data say this is how
you do it and so that that's a
from a practical guy's standpoint that's
me i i'm looking at it that way now
relationally what
we have found actually occurs when you
share
everything which is what the wedding
vows say
uh for sickness and health for richer
for poor and the old ones in the comic
book of common prayers say and
unto thee all my worldly goods i pledge
isn't that a pretty old english kind of
feel
unto thee all my worldly goods i pledge
in other words
i'm yours you're mine we're doing this
together period not
hey you lost your job i hope you work
that out
it's a little different and so getting
on the same page and when you can agree
on your spending you're agreeing on your
goals you're agreeing on your fears
you're carrying burdens together
and you're having celebrations together
versus high-fiving your roommate who
just got a raise
right what is that what does that
conversation sound like when you say
let's let's combine this what is his
reasoning um
so we have we tried that when we were
first married and like i said i'm
usually the very responsible one
um and quickly realized that he
could not be reeled in with um
you know spending um you're not his mom
yeah you're not his mom all right
again what is the conversation like when
you if you were to sit down tonight and
say hey
i want to revisit this let's let's join
let's
get one account what would his rebuttal
be
um i think he would be okay with that
because of
my financial stability i guess where my
concern is
is knowing that even though i've
lost my my job currently
i was in a pretty good financial
position
you know with the balance of my mortgage
my savings account
my retirement account um i think he
would be okay with that
because he may have access then to what
i have kind of saved and earned
but you don't you're not okay with it
no i'm not especially knowing that
um okay so part of part of you joining
it together means that we are both
grown-ups
and we are both setting goals and we're
both agreeing on
how we're going to do all our money he
gets a vote you get a vote we write it
down called a budget and we pinky swear
and spit shake that we're going to stick
to the contract
and then if he goes off the rails and
goes and buys something that is not on
that big
some big item comes on with a two
thousand dollar item and says oh look
what i did
uh he's broken the contract he's lied
and that has to be the new terms of this
deal and it sounds like you have a i may
miss something here it sounds like you
have a pronoun problem
you keep saying the money that you saved
and that you paid down
how long have you all been married 10
years 10 years yeah
i this may be a hymn problem right now
but it sounds like it's a you problem
it sounds like you are reticent to
receive him into this
into this new like dave said this new
contract well he has to be willing to
commit to the contract and that would
get rid of her
her problems with this but then you
can't you can't nickel and dime him on
the contract that's not what i'm talking
about but you say
hey we are going to lay out a budget we
both have input on it we both have a
vote
and then we are both agreeing to be
grown-ups and stick to it ain't your
mama
and usually that begins with the values
with a destination
conversation where are you headed yeah
what are you going to do where do we
want to go together
i want to have this house paid off in 10
years but where are we going to be
right and he's got to be a part of the
values of a part of the journey
conversation not a part about
the did you follow up my rule
conversation here's what's interesting
with anyone
married couples or otherwise if you say
i've got a group of leaders here inside
my company
when we can agree on where the money's
going to go
and what the goal is with the money we
create a
different level of spiritual
and emotional unity unity that's right
unity because you're communicating
jesus said your treasure is where your
heart is and when you can agree
on that you're combining hearts
and so i you know i don't dictate to our
team what the budget is they turn in a
budget on one of the profit centers and
vice president publishing preston that
just did this book with you he's going
to turn in a
publishing budget that includes what
he's going to make on redefining anxiety
and what it costs and those kinds of
things and then i'll look at that with
him and he and i may have a discussion
and make some adjustments
or his svp or his esvp or whatever it
would have that discussion and i might
get involved
but when we have finally come to
agreement on what we think we're going
to make and what we think we're going to
spend and the profit we're going to have
as a result in that business unit
we have now joined hearts and you know
what she
she she she said something that i want
to make sure everybody hears
she said and i think he's going to think
this
we have got to get out of other people's
heads we have to
we've got to look at they're strenuous i
know but we got to look at their
strenuous to be in their heads it's
exhausting it takes a lot of energy
you're
almost always wrong right you're almost
always wrong when you get in somebody
else's head and decide why they're about
to do something that he hadn't even done
it yet right
um join as one get on the same page with
where you're gonna be
join hearts join finances and get out of
each other's heads man
yeah one checkbook one budget one goal
one set of goals one set of fears that
are
shared and man when you do that
no stopping ding ding ding it goes
your probability of high quality
marriage your probability of wealth
building goes
way up and your probability of it not
being either otherwise
way down you have a roommate